que le dispositif de de l'article 15 a
été élaboré dans le cadre d'un travail
en amont préalable avec le Conseil
d'État sur les conditions dans
lesquelles on peut mettre à contribution
des grandes infrastructures la réponse
du Conseil d'État est est très claire
dit si vous appliquez une taxe
spécifique aux société d'autoroute alors
il y aura répercussion ce n'est pas
notre projet aujourd'hui le projet de
l'article 15 tient compte de l'avis du
Conseil d'État puisque nous mettons en
place une taxe sur les grandes
infrastructures conduisent à des
mobilités dit polluantes qui nous permet
de financer notamment notre plan
ferroviaire l'article 15 a fait l'objet
transmission au Conseil d'État dont
l'avis a été rendu et a été communiqué
au rapporteur général à sa demande le
rapporteur général de la commission des
finances en dispose mais nous avons calé
le dispositif suite à l'instruction avec
le Conseil d'État et aujourd'hui je peux
vous dire qu'il s'agit pas d'une taxe
spécifique sur les sociétés d'autoroute
mais bien une taxe sur les grandes
infrastructures c'est la raison pour
laquelle il est solide et qu'on ne peut
pas dire qu'il y aura une répercussion
sur les péages et donc sur les
automobilistes dans la mesure où ce
n'est pas une taxe
spécifique et donc je maintiens
l'analyse du gouvernement et mettrai
donc un avis favorable aux amendements
de suppression y compris dans
l'affectation qui est prévue on a besoin
d'affecter cette taxe à la FIF pour
financer des projets d'infrastructure
notamment décarbonés par ailleurs cette
taxe elle est ciblée on a mis un certain
nombre de critères que vous avez rappelé
sur la rentabilité supérieure à 10 % le
revenu supérieur à 120 120 millions
d'euros voilà donc il est aujourd'hui
équilibré non spécifique et il contribue
au financement de la la transition
écologique